Hello everyone. How are you guys doing?
I hope you guys are having a wonderful
day. And today we are here with a uh
revitalization of a very old favorite.
So if you guys have been around the
channel since the very beginning, you
guys will remember a series called
Worthless to Wall Street. And that's
what we're going to go ahead and start
back up now. I got the entire summer
free. I I don't have I have a lot of
spare time. Let's just say that. So, I
want to go ahead and get to merching
with this alt account that I have so
that I can do something efficient. And I
want you guys to kind of follow the
journey with me. So, basically what this
account's going to go ahead and do is
start at the Grand Exchange with 1GP.
Now, I did this last year. I think I
started with a mill and I turned it into
150 within a pretty decent amount of
time. Now, I have more time. So, we're
going to go ahead and see what we can
do. As you guys can see, there's some
stuff in the bank. We will not be
touching this. However, what we will
need to do is withdraw one coin. So,
that's where we will start. This is
going to be a little interesting. Um,
the one coin merch, I'm not entirely
sure as to what I need to go ahead and
do. So, I'm going to hop on over and
kind of look at some items real quick.
Yes,
finally, we were able to buy something.
I had to try a few different things. And
I tried a bronze dart tip. That didn't
work. I tried this candarin, or it's not
candin, but some sort of desert armband.
Yeah, that wasn't going to work either.
But we got ourselves a pair of iron
claws. They do say 500 GP. However,
according to GE Tracker, they only sell
for around 50 or so. So, I'm just going
to try to go for guaranteed like 45. I
don't know how long this will take to
sell, but 45 GP we can actually do
something with. 1GP is insanely hard.
And hopefully these don't take that long
to sell, but honestly, this took me like
a day and a half. So, finally, here we
are next day. And uh yeah, got the iron
claws to sell on. Now we have 40 GP.
We're finally cooking. I'm going to go
ahead. I might merge some salt peter. I
don't know if that's how you pronounce
it, but I remember on my main, this is
something that flipped relatively
quickly and is worth a little bit of
money. So, I'll be able to get a few of
them merch at the same time. Boom. Just
like that. It only took me a couple
minutes and all of them have bought. Go
ahead. Try to sell them on for I think
12 GP now is what we're going to try to
go for. And that will bring us up to 60.
Okay. Well,
here we go. So, I ended up actually
being able to kind of flip these salt
peters or whatever they are. The salt
I bought 12 for 84, Saul for 132.
And with that, we have bought a tribal
mask. This is important because
apparently I can sell it for around
4,000 coins if I decide to wait my time,
which I will indeed will, which I will
indeed will. All right. And there we go.
So, I did end up selling off the tribal
mask. Really nice profit right there.
Went ahead and flipped 132 into 4,000.
So, that's really nice. Going to try to
figure out something else I can do now.
Yes, there we go. So, made a bit more
money. Found some merches that'll do me
all right. This one and this one, not
too shabby. However, this black kite
shield was able to merch on for 3.1,000
GP margin, which relative to what we
have, that's insane. I'm gonna try to
buy about another three of these and see
if we can keep merching them because it
that I mean that merch only took me like
15 20 minutes which which with the
merches that I've been trying to do.
That is really nice. So, I'm happy with
it. And another 3.1K made. Oh man, we
got some stuff going on. So, as you guys
saw earlier, I've been flipping these
black kite shields for a little bit of
money. About 3.1K each. I think the
margins went down since I've already
bought about five and haven't been able
to sell off any. However, we do have a
recent happening and that comes in the
form of this myithil fullhelm G. So, I
saw it had a pretty good margin. So, I
went ahead and I was going to put an
offer for 200 coins per one and then as
you guys can see here, I ended up just
insta buying it for five coins. Sold it
for 9,000. Like, oh my god. And then, as
you guys just saw, we bought another one
while I was recording this clip for 200.
Now, I don't know if that's someone
testing to see if they can merch it, but
realistically, that's a really good
margin. And I just made 9K off a Myithil
Full Helm and might go ahead and make
another nine. And there we go. Another
Myithil Full Helm sold off. On top of
that, we have these Team Cape 12s, which
have kind of sold for just a crazy
amount lately. I'm going to go ahead and
throw them in for like 12K. I mean, I
don't expect it to sell, but if it does,
I'll be pretty happy. Oh my god, have we
done a lot.
So, I ended up leaving. Had to uh put in
some offers, but we'll go through them
all. As you guys can see, the Keb Claws
2.8K for all three of them, which I then
end up selling off for 19.2. Really nice
margin there. Admit plate legs T we sold
off for 13.2. I bought them for 4K. So,
really good profit there. Uh, five
Myithil full helms. G, I'll definitely
take that. These can all sell on for
about 8.5 somewhere around there. I
mean, even if the price up there says
that, that's not what I can sell them
for. I can definitely sell them for
higher.
[Laughter]
I told you. Jeez. So, we just turned a
3K merch into 50K. Oh my gosh. And uh
yeah, sold off some Yakhide. That was a
little bit obscure, but I paid 500 GP
for all that. Sold them off for 12.5.
With that said, I have one more tribal
mask right now. I sold off a couple team
capes. Um I ended up putting a lot of
money into these. Well, not a lot. 5.6K
in total. And so far, we've gotten more
money out. And we still have five capes
left. But with that said, I think I'm
going to go ahead and cancel off all
these offers. We've gotten up to quite a
decent amount of money and I'm going to
probably do some bigger merches now,
which is a little exciting. So, a lot of
stuff's been going on. Figure I'll go
ahead and kind of run you through what
I've kind of got going on. There was a
bunch of Lumberyard teleports that I've
now missed out on showing you guys. I'm
sorry about that. In total, we probably
made about 40 to 50k off of those. They
were really helpful for the merches. Uh
here you guys can see what I was working
on for my other account.
Yeah, so I definitely needed to use all
the accounts I could to go ahead and get
those scales that I have on my main
right now. Uh didn't use any money from
here obviously, but I've been merging
some uh teleports, some Zra teleports,
you guys can see here. Turned 196k into
220 and then went ahead and made another
13K on this seven merch. So from there,
we went ahead and bought on some purple
suits as you guys can see here. 242K for
the lot and went ahead and sold them off
for 250. So we'll continue on. And here
we are. So with a little bit more than
last time, as you guys can see, 335k we
are up to. Just kind of go through real
quick what I did. Uh I pretty much just
merched on eight eight Carol skirts for
about a 10k margin each. On top of that,
merched a little bit here about 14K off
some Zoro scales. had a crazy margin
like 6GP on scales. You never see that.
Here we are back again. So, this one
pretty big merch right here. Going to go
ahead and collect real quick. Uh yeah,
pretty solid to be honest. So, as you
guys can see, the Canon stand right here
138. Sold it on for almost a 30k profit.
And this Canon stand sold for 160K,
bought it for 105. So, that's a really
good profit. Uh the margin's kind of
gone, but we're up to 440K.
Oh man, got a little bit more cash now.
So, as you guys can see here, I was
merching on some Zami Dehide Tops. I was
making about 50K a merch and I was able
to merge about four of them, it looks
like. I think yeah, that that seems
about right. I had to sell off the last
one though for only a 15K margin cuz
they went down a little bit. And along
the way, I also was able to sell and buy
a little bit of Ninja implings for
decent amount of money as you guys can
see here. I mean, there's a good margin
on them. I sold out 15 right there for
about a 3k profit each. So, there's 50k
there. I made a little bit more earlier
on some that aren't shown, but yeah,
that's about where we are. All right,
guys. We have a lot to go over. Um I
think I'm going to start showing more um
merches in particular. However, at these
low levels or like low levels of
merching, you kind of just have a lot of
flips going on, so it's kind of hard to
keep up on. But as you guys can see
here, before this, I did buy one holy
sandal for the same profit. So, we were
making about 40k on each holy sandal. As
you guys saw, we sold one, two, three,
and four about I think five in total. So
that's around that was around a 200k
profit, which was really nice. Then we
sold on a couple armadal dehides for two
or 20k profit each. So in total, making
a decent amount of money, probably
around 250k off all those merches. And
then up here, this is where it gets
real. Not not this, but this. So I
bought the samurai, I don't know how to
say that word, but the samurai legs for
250k. And we scroll up and I sold that
one on for 540K,
which is insane. Like a 250 to 540K
merch. Like that is ridiculous. So then
I went ahead and bought on another two
for 250K and the price has gone down. So
I went ahead and sold one off for 390.
The other one's still selling. But in
total, if this sells off as well, we are
up to 1.4 mil. So really nice. And
finally, we are done selling off the
samurai legs. And I also had a little
merch in between where I went ahead and
made 45K on some Zora scales. They had a
5GP margin. Like what the hell is that,
but that's fine. I mean, I took
advantage of it for the time being. I
wasn't able to buy anymore, so almost up
to 1.5 mil. Oh boy. Canon pieces. I do
not understand. I mean, I guess I kind
of understand why these things are like
this, but not a whole lot. I mean, we'll
go ahead and look through the profit
here. I'll go ahead and collect this so
you guys have a better idea as to what
was going on right here. So, there's
just kind of a lot of cannon pieces. As
you guys can see though, I bought a
cannon barrel or actually three of them
in total, I do believe. Yeah, I bought
three of them or so for 117. I was
making 50k per one. As you guys can see,
I actually bought I think six. Yeah, six
in total for 117. Um, and then I go
ahead and sell them all off at 165,
which means we're making about 50k per
one, which means that was about 300k.
And I also made 70k on a cannon stand
right there. So, not too bad. But with
that said, this will be the end of the
episode. So, I really enjoyed this. We
went literally from one GP all the way
to 1916,000.
So, that is insane. We're almost up to 2
mil after the first episode. So,
hopefully you guys enjoyed. If you guys
did, make sure to leave a like. If you
guys want to see more of this, go ahead
and tell me about it down below. Tell me
what you guys want me to kind of look
forward to or what you guys want me to
kind of merch. If you enjoy my content,
make sure to hit that sub button so you
can see my videos as soon as I go live.
But uh yeah, with that said, I hope you
guys have a wonderful day and peace.